hi everyone thank you for joining us
today and a very warm welcome to the
state of print dnad talks this event is
part of the state of print exhibition
that is currently ongoing at the
national design center till 31st july
and is presented by fable supported by
the design singapore council and the
national design center
joining us on our panel today we have
vanessa extin founder and creative
director of block design
norio nakamura founder and creative
director of norio nakamura studio who
will be accompanied by translator kotoko
koya
pan lim co-founder and creative director
of kinetic singapore and last but not
least a moderator for today debbie
millman founder and host of design
matters media
with that let us now welcome debbie to
join us on screen please to officially
kick-start today's session debbie please
thank you so much felicia
it is such an honor to be here and i'd
like to welcome everyone to the state of
print a panel discussion to examine the
role of print from past to present and
into the future
today we're hoping to discuss and debate
the contribution print has offered to
society
print has a rich diverse history and has
been highly adaptable to the 20th 21st
century
we strongly believe as a panel that
print is not dead and nowhere near dying
today we'll be talking about how we're
adapting our practices to the times
we're living in while still ensuring the
quality of our craft
i'm joined today by three phenomenal
practitioners and i'd like to introduce
them to you i'm going to introduce each
one individually before they speak
and then after their individual
contributions i'll follow up with a
question
of my own
in the meantime please feel free to add
your questions to the q and a section at
the very bottom of the zoom panel and
we'll do
as many questions as we possibly can
after each of the speakers present
so i'd like to first introduce vanessa
eckstein vanessa founded block in 1998
after a highly lauded career working at
some of the top design studios in north
america
guided by the belief that design is at
its best when it serves society
she has collaborated with some of the
world's leading contemporary artists
photographers architects and authors on
initiatives that blend cultural
awareness humanity
and a love of art to advance society and
business alike
please join me in welcoming our first
speaker vanessa eckstein
vanessa the floor is yours
hello uh thank you so much for the
invite thank you debbie for the lovely
intro
and
i'm going to start straight i have a
cough i'm going to clarify that if
i apologize for my cough that i'm
carrying but i'm going to jump straight
to the presentation
everybody sees everything okay
yes
okay so um
thank you so much i wanted to start by
um
uh telling a little bit of the places i
beam i'm over originally from buenos
aires argentina
but life has taken me to many places
from buenos aires to l.a
to new york
to a lay again i think i ping pong
between cities to toronto
to mexico city to toronto to berlin and
toronto the reason this is important is
because we are and i am as a student as
a person nomadic at heart and the
um moving and flowing between countries
and culture has been the essence of a
lot of the work we do
this um
pres this uh image that i'm starting
with now that i want to share
is a work by joaquin torre garcia a
uruguayan artist and i'd like to start
with this because i think that what we
do is actually question the foundations
of everything we consider annoying he
wanted to challenge the traditional
frame of mind and reposition the south
as the new north how does the world
change when we understand it just
slightly differently
our studio is based on that in always
exploring and always looking at the
possibility
of pushing it further and
moving between the boundaries of design
we are experimental by nature
curious by heart
and um
and i think that we try to always keep
on questioning that that we considered a
preconception
uh this image is a map of the um
of the human knowledge and the reason i
want it and it's done by the rod and i
wanted to start with this because as we
talk about print and digital and as we
start understanding that how we know and
how we feel that meaning is not a
knowing but a feeling an emotional
feeling of our bodies we understand that
when we're designing
a book
which is something that we do many many
times at block we're not only designing
uh the content but we're connecting
emotionally to its rhythm
i've always thought a book design is
actually like music you understand it
i think i just skipped one so i'm going
to try it again you understand it both
from its spacing both from its movements
its spaces in between
um the the sensibility
the texture
uh
college this is a book we just launched
and works both
uh with heavy materiality like um
concrete but then his work is spacious
so how we think about
the the project
within a
object
is information that we bring the texture
the materiality the felt design is as
important as the content itself because
it's a revelation of it
as a studio we are always involved in
projects that push us
we're small we choose projects that we
love
and and we try to take on projects that
will shift society and move it forward
this is girl meets money rethinking the
way women relate to money and opening
the path for investment in a space that
has been
very small and very male oriented and
understanding the money is energy and
that we carry a blueprint how can we
shift that how can we open the
conversation to a diverse part of the
society
um this we always start up our projects
with walls this maybe was my happiest
place in the world when i went to the
studio and i had this particular wall
for maybe a month
in the studio uh if you can recognize
some work it's not ours it's actually
elizitski it's i'm trying to say duchamp
uh it's all the movements mainly
avant-garde artists and
designers as well um that served society
that pushed or that challenged um
society or culture in in some way or the
other
this was a project we got invited to we
developed the content we had incredible
luck to be able to
get many of this work
given to us
for for this project and what we try to
do in most of our projects is try to
find different ways of meaning to um
create a dialogue between mandela and a
c happening to see what those
conversations is inspire
it isn't just about
sending you the exact same understanding
of it but creating new ways of meaning
creating new pathways into understanding
the content
and in this particular
uh issue we had images from magnum this
was tahir square
and i always uh feel very connected to
this when we used one same image
to
overpose itself on itself but this
uprising
uh is interesting because all as we talk
about prince and digital
all the social media at the time had
been censored they went down people
could not access twitter they could not
see anything that was digital but this
uprising and this
congregating of people happened because
of printed flyers so for me it has this
incredible narrative of what happens
when the assumed or the platform or the
bigger platform that we assume is the
one that is existing falls down
and what about those other places that
actually
really make us rethink and go back to
where we were and how we connected to
each other
i think we're living in a
space of complete overstimulation over
neural stimulation where we get a lot of
information we all access the same
amount of knowledge but in reality um
we're overwhelmed by it and we're going
less deeper
and
vaster but let's deeper so between the
concept of history and innovation
the most important word is and
and and is a space that we actually like
to live in
um i'm interested in the spaces in
between the ones that hold both human
experience and then clear answers the
ones that hold the possibility of the
future and the playground to the unknown
um we
a couple of uh years ago just just as
covid was hitting before covert six
months before covet we decided to move
the studio to berlin for two years with
this idea that we could actually
embrace him familiar move ourselves out
of that that we know normally in our
everyday life 90 is familiar and 10 is
unfamiliar with this move 90 was
unfamiliar so the beauty of this
experience was to actually try to put
ourselves in a place where we don't even
we didn't even know
what the studio was like we rented
apartments um
it was actually maybe the craziest
business idea possible uh it made no
business sense except that it made human
sense
uh i wanted our studio to live this
experience together at the time nobody
was doing things through zoom
or or anything like it so when covet hit
six months later we found that this idea
that seemed so crazy became brilliant by
essence just by pure
human connectivity
because we were already digital but most
important because we had connected as a
studio so profoundly
this is a book we designed
for lichen mexico from mexico city about
all the people that illuminated mexico
all the ideas all the artists all the
food they came from mexico to the world
to honor
that which
you know many times mexico looks beyond
itself
to get approval and this was an honoring
of itself to the world
uh and again this was we we have a we
feel very connected to this project
because
everything doing this project in a place
we didn't know with nothing available
that we were accustomed to but it's
elements of challenge and now we find
them
incredibly rewarding
uh we work on identities um
i brought this one because i like the
idea that this is a hotel we just
launched in picton and this idea of the
royal but the
the um
essence of this
uh project comes from
place the sense of place it looks like
digitalized but it's actually crochet
that looks like it would be me but be a
bitmap so this blurring of the lines
between what is what isn't this single
lacrim of the digital but actually comes
from the most essential craft is spaces
and languages that we like to explore
you don't quite know where it holds but
it's in the in between of both
and when it comes to publications we
were invited to design this publication
um for
cannabis uh one of the first cannabis
magazines as soon as we were launching
it covet hit so we went from a pub from
a printed publication
to a digital publication that had to be
ready in a month
that experience the craziness of it was
incredible and
and also how we could translate in a way
that would honor each one and not
compete to create a dialogue between
between both mediums
we work in many spaces um honestly we
we really it's very uh cross-sectional
um this is a book we designed for mocha
here
in toronto
and um we designed the book as well as
the space as well as the products
um
part of what we like about this is that
we like the blurring of all boundaries
the space that crossover between these
boundaries both in medium but also in
design other again the spaces that we're
truly interested in
uh the ones that truly spur the
imagination stir the imagine the
imagination sorry i have my cough
imagination
uh this is uh
this was always our sense of
uh
understanding a work to make sure that
we are i'm gonna play it again open
enough
porous enough curious enough
uncomfortable enough unfamiliar enough
to actually
that take on and keeping on absorbing
the world into us we are
that
influence we do need to keep on pushing
ourselves into other mediums so when the
world
went into lockdown we launched a product
line and this is another project that we
had started before
coved we had seen
um and that the world needed more
interaction more humanity that we needed
to you know cut things down that we need
to go back to our values uh we stood on
the philosophy that if enough is plenty
um
and we wanted to honor conviviality so
when corbett hit this project seemed to
be aligned completely with what we
believed
we were missing
more of us together more sharing more
time
to be connected
um
so interesting enough this is one of the
projects that we went in to form not
only into print but into form into the
physicality of it
into the experience of it humanity is
for us the essence of design in every
possible way
um and we stand on some very simple
beliefs
idealism is a precondition you need to
believe everything is possible always um
you know there's always another way has
always been our philosophy the nose are
there we want to at least try to shift
whatever we can towards the world we
want to change uncertainty is intrinsic
to the process our berlin experience was
all about uncertainty to me this is
something i've enjoyed and lived all my
life but my studio actually needed to
experience it and this is the one of the
things that they came back saying we had
never
lived uncertainty now covet hit and now
we've understood that this actually is
um
something we need to embrace in order to
move forward
slant to shift your perspective always
wherever you stand move it just a little
bit move it far but see what happens on
the other side the edges is what
interests us the edges of every possible
conversation not the right answer not
the wrong answer but what lies in
between what is that edge that would
move us to one place or the other
easiest soul is we found that all the
projects that actually have taken our
soul are the ones that give it back to
us and those many times require time
something that we as a society don't
value enough but time is important and
chaos as a way of thinking as creatives
we have to embrace chaos our minds have
to wonder our minds have to be able to
hold complex and paradoxical thoughts
in order to be able to free ourselves
into whatever pathway and creative
pathway we want to go to
i think my time is up i was trying to be
really good i'm sorry if i was fast to
keep it into my 15 minutes uh you ha you
must have one grand passion this is
holster she's an artist i actually have
to admit we have many passions but we
hold true that we always should be
working from our hearts and hold really
really one one at least grand passion
thank you so much
i'm gonna
try to find my yeah here stop
thank you
wow vanessa i am
blown away um i saw your presentation
before today but hearing you articulate
your ideas around how you make things
is just breathtaking um i have about 10
questions for you but i'm going to try
to limit it to just a few so that
we can hear everybody
else's presentations too
first of all um it was the first time i
saw your company name
typographically spelled the way you did
with
the b the colon the l
the o with the line through it and the
backwards k can you talk a little bit
about how you do how and why you do that
yes it's you know i
we
i'm trying to see where do i start i
started the company almost 21 years ago
you know there was no interest there was
nothing but i actually got a master's
degree in l.a in los angeles that's why
i went i moved from argentina in
intercultural design when there were no
masters and nobody was talking about
intercultural nobody was talking about
cultures internet did not exist
and i wanted a name block actually was a
political
magazine of the avant-garde so i wanted
a name that would reflect
this philosophy that we design is at its
best when it literally changes and
serves society at a time and please
remember
that time no designer was political no
designer was pushing a cause of change
no designer so and it wasn't that i
wanted to be
in it wasn't that i'm saying oh i did it
before anybody actually was quite the
opposite i lived a military dictatorship
it pushed me to have that awareness and
that consciousness that design had to be
a movement towards something different
and that's a great motivation that's a
fire that is keeps your creativity alive
without it you know i don't know where
where to get it where to get that so
why those letters i want it to be from
many places i wanted to be
non-defined and i've always wanted a
studio that wasn't defined that really
you know especially in that time that
was open
to many possibilities and
the more i'm the older i get it the more
i want it it actually is
more of a challenge to cross those
boundaries for myself and the people
with us as well within the studio it's
part of our culture
design that you showed that just had me
salivating was the work that you did for
i believe it's a museum in toronto
how did you get your client to allow you
to
uh create the type on the windows
vertically as opposed to horizontally
you know what you have to give credit to
the people around you um honestly
you know first of all this is a studio i
have i'm gonna honor the people in my
studio that are you know
that push it the way i push it but the
truth is that the the the client in this
case um i'm actually seeing them on
friday on another exhibit
you know they they they embraced it and
and this is part of
i don't try to convince clients i try to
choose them well and that's the
difference i choose them well from the
beginning when i align with clients from
the beginning i know that wherever i go
we're coming we're going together and
and it is a journey together and it
makes the work in the studio uh such a
beautiful process i'm i'm very selective
but it is an intuitive selection it is
not a mind selection i know when i meet
a client when the conversation
becomes this you want to actually spend
a night having a beautiful dinner and
talking most probably it's an amazing
client and we try to choose clients that
way
it's an interesting and an interesting
conundrum for young designers i remember
talking to milton laser
um very similar type of response to the
type of clients that he wants or being
very choiceful and selective what's your
advice for younger designers that might
not have that freedom of choice that
might
be
really um
struggling to find those like-minded
clients to to find that
mutuality and thank you for asking
because i think it's a very valid
question to start i actually had this
philosophy when i started the studio
and um and and i didn't have that backup
so i did take this and so i want to put
that perspective i did take this
philosophy early on in my life and it
has paid off so if you do decide to try
to find now try to find that that it
does pay off now one advice would say do
the work you want to get if you're
waiting
for the work and this is one thing i've
always considered
what type of work do you want to do
don't wait for it you need to show that
you've done it and and many times i
haven't done the stuff but you need to
thought show that you think this way
that you feel this way that you move
this way it's not just about the work
it's about how you move and you feel now
through my career i've educated and have
been educated by clients as well so it's
not just oh we come as you know and and
we show our work and it's a proof no
this this is a relationship whoever
tells me that they hate the client or
they then you know in all honesty
clients are like partnerships and
everything in life
we're human and the best are when we
respect each other and we have a
relationship teach them and let them
teach you
and and i think that you you will grow
into
be able to honestly attract because i
think at this point i say select to be
honest with you debbie i think i don't
even get the bad ones i think they don't
even come to me like they
they must be scared or something but
they end up showing up and i always
wonder how can i how can how can they
know that this
this could work and you start attracting
certain types of projects
and and certain types of values and
certain types of people and and i find
that a great honor in my life it's been
a beautiful journey they end up coming
back or becoming friends
yeah that's very similar to something
that irma boom said about her work as
well that ultimately
uh people understand what she's trying
to do
and and those type of people come to her
for younger designers that still might
be hoping to have that type of
relationship with their clients um one
thing stefan zachmeister said to a class
of mine when he was coming to guest
lecture was
um if you don't have the kind of work
that you want in your portfolio make it
yourself anyway exactly and that often
can
help attract a different type of
clientele
exactly
they listen well i'm gonna just the
listener yeah
it sounds so simple learn how to listen
because when you listen you know exactly
what worries them you pay attention to
that and let me tell you this side they
they let you free so listen listen well
and you will be able to have a much
vaster playground and then absolutely
i i want to really underline that um
one of the things that i've learned in
my career especially as somebody that
does
quite a lot of listening now in
interviews
is most people don't really listen you
know they talk talk talk talk talk and
then they stop talking and wait for the
other person to stop talking so they can
start talking again and and i think that
that's a wonderful a wonderful way of
trying to
get yourself out of it so much is by
being very still and listening to what
somebody's actually saying i actually do
want to ask you one more question before
we move on
you talked about living with uncertainty
um and and trying to stay open
living with uncertainty is sort of my
achilles heel i i like to be in control
of everything i'd like to know what's
happening next i like things to be very
the same same same same so i'm prepared
or i like to prepare prepare so that i
know what's happening or i feel like i i
know it's gonna happen how do you live
with that uncertainty give us one tactic
to sort of hold the uncertainty without
running away from it
okay so maybe for me what i've realized
so you and this i discovered not long
ago you know these are not theories
these are just discoveries i find about
myself and i try to share i discovered
that i am at my very best when i'm at
the edge the edge of a cliff you know
people would say oh my god you're going
down for something in my heart knows
that that edge is holding ground but i
have the possibility to jump
the excitement that you know the
possibility to fall and is also there it
is always there and that's that's
uncertainty actually but i always see
that what the benefit of that jump and
that possibility to fly
holds such strength to me that it's
worth the being in that edge and it's
worth the job and it's worth the leave
so how do we hold uncertainty
for me
is that my life my world the people i
meet by doing those leaps have have been
such wonderful like i think berlin was
an incredible lead like berlin was
please debbie i'm a small studio i do
not have the economy to pay for
apartments pay for a studio pay all the
tickets pay for two months this was
honestly
anybody in business would have crossed
this as the worst economical idea
and and
hit we were like you know the experience
was incredible but it it served it fed
us it was like
holding so much um energy for us to
actually survive covet together as a
team and and try to find our way um
those are the leaps those are the leaps
that come from instinct and you do not
have the answer and you hope as
a great poet said sometimes you have to
ask the question and wait and know that
the answer will arrive that's how i hold
my uncertainty someday
it will just come back
thank you vanessa i think um you're a
wonderful example
of being able to rely on oneself in a
way to make even better work and your
work is
spectacular it's good that i had i was
on mute while you were presenting
because i kept going
oh my god oh my god
thank you thank you thank you
um i'd like to introduce everyone to our
next speaker but i'd also like to remind
everybody to please uh include your
questions if you have questions for
vanessa for any of our speakers we will
have an open conversation after all of
our presenters show their work
norio nakamura was born in kanagawa
japan
he established his own design company
nakamura norio studio in 1997.
since then he has engaged in a wide
spectrum of creative activity and has
provided artistic direction for
playstation games and smartphone
applications and his most recent work
includes creating children's books and
organizing workshops for children we are
also joined by
i'm sorry
kotoko koya who will be translating
fenoria thank you so much and my
apologies for um that misstep in names
hello debbie and hello everybody
first of all how glamorous are the two
of you can we please discuss
the most stylish people here hands down
including yourself debbie oh hardly
it's it's 8 30 in the morning here in in
the united states so yeah i'm just glad
i'm i've brushed
hello everybody good morning good
evening uh and good day
i'm nooryo nakamura
[Music]
typical asians
asian weather is very hot and wetty uh
where we're in the middle of this very
wettest summer although i heard that in
london uh is also facing a very hot hot
summer um but today we had a little bit
of rain so it's a little bit cooler
and
we're happy to be here
with you guys
[Music]
as as you know every day's uh
topics you know the uh this pandemic is
is have completely changed our life
and uh some of you have very difficult
time and some of you have you know kind
of used to to this new normal
and uh as for us in tokyo uh the the
number has hit the the most
biggest number uh in the in the past
let's say two years three years
however
the tokyo looks very active
people are
in the street uh of course with the mask
but we're we're kind of
trying to get back to the
[Music]
so today's thing about
the state of print
and i'm a graphic designer and of course
i i work with with print with most of my
projects so
i have selected some of my uh project
and hope is uh is something to do with
the the theme today
[Music]
in my career i
as devi has kindly introduced me um i
have very various fields
with my my design
i make this i make games i make
animations i make some digitals and of
course
the design for the print
and and i especially from the very
beginning of my career i especially find
print is very important and very
interesting medium and especially print
is something that um that can
communicate something in
a still stop-motion but has a has a rich
rich engagement
as you scroll down the page
very quiet or maybe the audience is
going like oh
[Music]
so this book uh this visual book is um
is a is a kind of a way of communication
that i kind of explore i wanted to i'm
going to have this print as a
a kind of a new communication style so
if you just flip
flip the page uh you can you feel like
it's it's almost like a
a communication that you have with
someone but you are actually uh flipping
the book and seeing the video still
visual
on my own
a
[Music]
because of the nature of the print
the information information you can
apply on the surface of the
of the print is limited
but somehow i somehow
i i wanted to take that as an
advance
and i wanted the audience to to to boost
their imagination and to
let them translate what they're seeing
freely
and so this is kind of uh
experimental approach
with the with the with the uh with the
reader
i know
a
and the next project uh you're seeing is
a poster this is a
single poster
and with the same approach with the the
art book you just saw um i i very much
like the
uh the way to express something in in
let's say one moment
and
i
tend not to not to have too many
information within the visual and in
this way i let the audience
engage more with the vigil and let them
imagine
what's the story behind
and this is another
different
poster
is
so this poster is is
made of uh
some numbers of series of poster and one
poster is is a continuation of the one
before
so there is a story uh that carry on
within this series of posters
so you can see the one before
so the first the first pose they
obviously you see is a suitcase and then
the second poster
is actually inside the plane but the
shape carry on from the previous uh
suitcase shape
and when i make these posters uh i try
to make uh some sequence within the
series of poster but i also um try to
leave some space um some
space for imagination but still has a
kind of a linear
through the whole series of posters
and
moving on to the next project
yes
[Music]
i as i just explained i i always try to
not to say too much or not to put too
many information that gives one single
uh
story i always let i always try to let
the audience
understand or interpret so
um try not to try not to explain too
much but this is a presentation so i
need to do some a little bit of
explanation
so let me
go through this
[Music]
of course um it depends on the project
that i use
but um
in in most of the project i try
not to
put all the information too much explain
and
and make everything so clear that nobody
would have like a question
but
i always believe that to have an
engagement with the audience or the
listener or the reader is to have a have
a space for communications to have a
space for
imagination and that brings
more attention rather than giving a full
spec of
information and
so that's why my posters were always
something that is
seems to be less information or seems to
be
uh
some blank spacing with it but that's
kind of an approach that i always
challenge myself and challenge my my
audience
and the last project that i want to show
you is um
exhibition of exhibition
i did
the visual communication that i did
for
2120 on design site in tokyo
is
this exhibition the title was a unit
exhibition of unit
yes
[Music]
this was
quite an interesting project that i um i
was happily involved
first of all my my main role was to
design the visual communication the
identity for the exhibition
but also
i was part of the team of the exhibition
from the building the concept of the
exhibition and actually
thinking about the space design and the
communication design and how to make a
bridge within those
designs
some of them
so and these are actually the um inside
the exhibition and as you can see
everything is divided into the unit of
each element
so the books and some products or
some
unknown
uh or or or broken into a unity
foreign
and the way this exhibition uh
was this how how this was designed is
that first of all um
i have designed the visual identity for
the exhibition along with the team
and the space design team
would then
use that system
the visual system in my my
my poster my identity poster
into the physical space
so there is a strong relation with the
uh
the poster
and the actual exhibition which i
thought it was very important for the
for the visitor to to to have the same
experience whether looking at the poster
or whether looking at the exhibition
and it was a great um let's say teamwork
uh i was lucky to work with uh for the
for the space design it was designed by
our architect space design team called
in japan and there were also
very
talented writers or
lighting designers
we all share the same system
from this
video and so it was such a great
experience and it was a great process
making this whole exhibition
yes
foreign
so this is actually um that was not the
last project sorry this is the last
project we're gonna share and i'd like
to share my
project uh for the children's book which
i have done
many for the past many years and and
children's book is very i think it's
very important because obviously it's a
physical
medium that you engage with the children
and i i like to show um
[Music]
so with the same approach with the
the project i just saw with the posters
and
exhibition visual communication
my style is is always
more or less the same i
the less information
will give
more imagination
that's more communication with the
readers so i use that the scenario
with for the children's book
throughout this um
throughout the process of making
children's books for many years i have
learned so much about how
children
behave children understand and
and i i'm confident that even two years
old or three years old uh
even with these kind of very abstract uh
images uh they can understand and they
can
even imagine within their within their
mind and brain and make the
higher resolution
within their within the imagination so i
tend to use this approach and hopefully
this is
kind of a
kind of educational approach and
stimulating their imagination
[Music]
communication
and whenever i i make a book
i often do like a reading
reading day
with the small kids and i flip through
the
books uh in front of the kids and they
can they can enjoy the
the texture and the sound and
the paste i turn the pages and this
experience i i think is very important
and that's all for my presentation thank
you very much thank you noria thank you
to koto uh just absolutely stunning
um i have a couple of questions um first
the first book that you showed with the
toaster was that a personal project or
was that a project for a client
[Music]
it started as a self-promotion
project
but one of the publishers saw it and
and they they approached to me and and
then became
part of their publication
wonderful
it's absolutely fantastic
i love how
in all of your projects
that you've shown today you play with
perspective
but
a sort of language-less perspective
it's a perspective that we have to
create
are you very intentionally choosing
not to use
language
there is a need um i i would i would use
a text or some
form of information but um i think that
a visual is is more stronger than
text so whenever i find there's a
confident that i can make it
make sense
then
i choose not to use text
one thing that you mentioned was that
you like
to
let your audience create the narrative
and interpret
the story on their own have you ever
discovered that
someone from the audience
created a narrative that was quite
different than what you intended
[Music]
so for example yes oh absolutely always
a
different intervention coming from the
audience and especially with the
children's book that i show in the last
part
because the kids are so curious always
curious and they wanted to
to
spot the animal's name so
it almost became like a
kind of a trigger to
bring the imagination and it's almost
like making a quiz
but of course that's something that
something
brings me joy and surprise because the
how they interpret is different and
that's very normal um because you always
think that one everybody thinks the same
but then
it's not so that always brings me back
uh to to refresh my
mind
wonderful thank you this is my last
question before we move on to our next
speaker
um you talked about you're in the second
to last project not the children's book
but the exhibition before that that you
were looking to create the same
experience by looking at the poster
and the exhibition the exhibition is a
three-dimensional physical experience
the poster is a two-dimensional
experience
and one that requires a bit more
interpretation
can you talk a little bit about how you
create how you went about creating that
same experience
[Music]
foreign
it was kind of um um
made by this
limited schedule that we we got from the
client the exhibition uh first of all
there was it was a quite a limited time
that we got for the
production
and we needed to make the poster in the
beginning even though the exhibition uh
the composition of the exhibition wasn't
uh ready yet so we need to start with
the poster
me
um so
the the brief i got from the
exhibition was simply the the title the
exhibition the unit
and so i have to interpret the
the word unique into
visual but but also i have to make it
into some kind of a visual system or
visual language
that could explore into three dimensions
so
my
graphic in the poster uh it looks very
simple but actually there is a system
uh i i intended
and and after the the poster was
designed uh the space designers or the
interior designer took that role into
the three dimension
thank you so much your work is
absolutely gorgeous and it's such an
honor to speak with you today norio and
thank you
for the wonderful translation thank you
our last speaker last but not least by
any means is pan lim who is the
co-founder and creative director of the
creative agency kinetic singapore and he
strongly believes that creating work
without an idea
is a sin
and this belief has earned him over 500
industry awards
he is a firm proponent of giving back
and pan plays an active role in
nurturing younger generations and
sharing his passion for creativity
so pan welcome to the stage and for our
audience
this is another opportunity for you to
contribute questions after pan is
finished i'll ask him a question or two
and then we'll open it up to the entire
audience i have a number of questions
already but please feel free to add more
if you'd like
pan welcome to the stage
thank you debbie for the introduction oh
look at that background everyone wow
it's kind of a mess right
now it's kind of amazing yeah so yeah
thanks for having me uh and thanks to
all the
hard work from the organizers
that put this whole
so-called
talking session together i'm really
grateful to be part of the speaking
panel and i'm here also very happy to
later on if there are questions for for
me i'll be more than happy to share so
for now i will quite quickly
share a screen first
so
today i've chosen to talk about
what we did during the pandemic i think
the last
two years have been
i think life-changing
uh for for many i can't speak for the
rest of the world uh what what happens
uh during the pandemic but i will speak
largely from the lens of being
what being kinetic in singapore during
that two years
so
um
[Music]
as with most of my presentation the most
important slide is dislike i think um
kinetic will be nothing without the team
behind it uh which i always call them
the family kinetic family so i think we
have been
a like small agency independent
uh but we really have passion in what we
do and really want to put our best to
what we do and i think that's pretty
much the the essence of us
and this this photo that you see was
after one of the campaign that we have
done which i'm going to share later and
we were all featured on the national
paper
and um this was a recent photo taken by
us uh it was just i think
uh just two weeks ago first of july it
was um
you know i was celebrating our kinetics
20 23rd birthday
and
it's something that i think it's
important to me that's why i put it into
this presentation deck because i think
again i would like to stress uh me alone
i can't accomplish much but as a team we
can do a lot
okay so this is something that uh
i like a lot this chinese teaching
um it says
shall go never be changed then change
the path shall the path cannot be
changed then change the method shall the
method cannot be changed then change the
environment shall the environment cannot
be changed then change the point of view
shall the point of view cannot be
changed then change the way of thinking
i think um
for most part of our projects while we
have not sat down and say oh this is the
kind of thinking that we want to go into
but
at kinetic we like to
challenge the status quo
we like to make sure that whatever we do
comes out as fresh as we can
and during the pandemic
i would say that the print industry or
the printing industry has taken a big
hit i think most festivals most uh
exhibitions uh were all put on us
were put on a halt and a lot of the
printing materials are also stopped
so
for us
we did feel that um
it's quite sad of course you know
because
as a print designer
or rather print trained designer i mean
i've always loved
the interaction with people and whatnot
and when i knew that
this is going to affect our industry of
course i'm saddened but at the same time
i also do believe that in any situation
in any adversity it's also opportunities
so
i do not i do see the panama as
something bad but i think it's also
something important for us to learn and
take a lesson from
so quite quickly we went into
when when singapore went to a lockdown
the first few projects that we worked on
was a self-initiated project called
thank you delivery heroes so
we were quite
sad that everybody have to stay home and
work and you know whatever we needed
when we have to dispatch documents to
one another or
to deliver food there's always the
delivery heroes or
we call them they always deliver stuff
to us and we thought it would be nice if
we can create a campaign to say thank
you to them and that was what we did and
we sat down and think so it was a simple
brief right just to launch a campaign to
thank the delivery industry
then during the thought process we sat
down we discussed how can we launch a
campaign without stepping out of the
house since we are in a lockdown
going digital is a sensible way since
it's a lockdown makes sense
how do we bridge digital to print during
a pandemic i think that was a very big
question as well how do we get a message
out without us printing anything so that
resource is almost zero i mean this is a
self-initiated project so margins or
rather there's no margin so spending is
import is a important factor to look
into
how do we make use of the thousands of
existing front doors
and home printers owned by others to
help promote the campaign how do we get
the audience to like share and
participate in this campaign and how do
we get the media to be interested in the
story so these a lot of questions that
were floating around were trying to
answer them
and finally we found our answer and i'm
gonna show a case video on it
from groceries and essentials to sweet
cravings and more delivery workers bring
them all
there was a time when we would rush to
open the door for them
then came covert 19.
how do we show our gratitude to those
who stay out as we stay home
when the door is in the way
what if we turn the barrier into a
conduit of thanks
by using the door for thank you notes
thank you delivery heroes
we created 24 posters for our delivery
heroes with thank you messages that
ranged from the heartfelt to the cheeky
the designs were put on our website and
everyone was invited to print them and
put them up
from one door to another the movement
spread
and in just a few days hundreds of doors
across the country joined in
even cafes and restaurants took part
no printer no problem many got creative
and made the posters by hand
thank you delivery heroes soon became a
part of the national conversation on
covet 19 efforts the idea is simple
people can download the posters from the
website add on them as they like and
stick them on their doors
with the community's participation our
message of thanks was received by
delivery workers all over singapore
so while doors remain closed our little
initiative made sure that they are no
barrier to open hearts
so we were quite heartened
uh that the kind of campaign took off uh
and the people participating were pretty
passionate about it they share online
uh when they did not have printers they
really went ahead and draw the posters
there are a few that i would like to
highlight that i thought was really
funny this is one of them you make my
day bloom even though i'm stuck on zoom
because back then everybody was like
zooming you know
then we have the next one where you go
the distance for us doors ain't stopping
our love for you
i mean that's when i left and then the
hero comes along so our lives can carry
on thank you delivery heroes so we like
to do all this like a bit cheeky fun
stuff and
i mean end of the day while we were
having fun this also um
how do i say it connected with people
and to you today actually we still get
people uh putting up posters there and
sometimes they'll message us and they
say that they really have a good laugh
and that made us happy as well
okay so that's for this project
the next project
is for a long time client mini mini as
in mini cooper the car okay so we did a
mini tomotrope
uh to our overseas audience who might
not know what an
is okay i took down the definition
online because i've never explained what
ang pao is angpao is a gift of money
packed into
traditionally a rape packet
uh and given as tokens of good wishes
during auspicious occasions
uh like
chinese new year okay so we
we kind of did uh every year for mini
because
uh it's for to so-called gift as a gift
to the drivers who bought the mini car
and that year in 2021 uh it was like
kind of one year after the first after
2020 which was the beginning of the
pandemic
we were all thinking
what's that one important thing that
we really miss and
truth true enough is actually
the gathering of
people the the human touch like you want
to be near each other but because of the
rules we were all kind of separated and
we thought
what a nice idea we can come up with an
unpower right
that we can feature festive scenes
using
this technique right so we have two
images each on one side of the arm pile
and after when you spin it right
you'll see the full effect that actually
what we are showing is the gift of
togetherness
so we have uh done into a couple of
scenes so this is to show close friends
we miss close friends gathering having
food together so this one of the
scenario the other scenario is
i in typical chinese uh during chinese
new year when we go uh
and visit the elders we always give them
a pair of mandarin oranges and we will
say
a few lines of
auspicious
messages
and in this case what we have done is
two images one on each side and the
video goes like that
for the next scenario
we were all kind of
locked at home so we also miss visiting
our neighbors our friends and this
pals celebrates that
and
i've uh i've got a few friends who they
have partners that were overseas and
they were kind of separated for
the almost that two years so this is one
of the
so-called
dedicated to them in a way
okay
so i mean before i move on to my last
project um just want to say that
i mean
in a situation where uh
things are not going well during the
pandemic i i believe that it's also
within our ability and our capability
to think of ideas that might you know
give people a smile make people happy um
after we launch and
give given out all these unpops because
they are not for sale they are only for
mini drivers who own a car who own a
mini car and shortly after that we we
saw that they were all selling on a
secondhand market and they were selling
very expensive and again those are like
funny things you know things that we
know that okay
it meant something and people wanted to
buy this special limited edition piles
and um
you know when he put a smile to our
faces uh to know that our project has um
been so-called people like it right so
okay so the last project is a kind of
like a personal family project of mine
so rubbish feminism is
so far now currently we have launched 10
issues and 10th issue was supposed to be
launched in 2020 and our first issue was
launched in 2013 when we visited tokyo
and kyoto that's why you call it google
translating to kyoto so when we were
there we used the google translate
app and you know it's gonna be
inaccurate and that's the whole fun
about it
and
we were all planning the family was all
planning to head back to tokyo
in 2020 when of course we know that kobe
19 came and the borders were closed and
we knew that
we are unlikely to travel
and
we were all thinking what should we do
should we change the topic should we
plan another way and
and then we figured if we can't go to
japan we'll just have to bring japan to
us
again this is really just thinking
trying our best to think out of the box
so you can see on the left that's the
scene that was launched in 2013 on the
right actually is
what we plan to do for the 10th issue so
what i did was i
opened the old files the fa file saved
in 2013 and open it up and and we're
just gonna
redesign over it so i'm gonna print the
same exact symbol it's just i'm just
gonna add pages so in the end hundreds
and hundreds of unique rubber stamps
have been created just for this purpose
i'll zoom in here you can see that for
number issue number one on the left is
purposefully haphazardly stamped with
number 10 even the dates has been
changed and the price as well
so what you see now is the actual book
that was actually printed so you can see
that it's actually still the same book
it's just presented very differently as
a new one
and this is of course with the full
package look with all the elements put
together
here you can see on the sample the photo
on the left was shot in 2013 the one on
the right
shot 2020 you can see this is exactly
the same design but i added in tip ins
extra stickers
ink stamps and
and other leaflets and stops of stuff
okay so a very short video on the left
you're going to see the 20 version and
the 20 20 versions on the right
[Music]
okay so
um before i sign off i just want to
share the same slide again about the
state of mind actually
what
i always wanted to
when i when i think about projects i
think the most important thing is always
try to think different
try to
uh think of a refreshing eye way of
so-called solving a problem if not then
think of a solution
so with that uh i will end my
presentation thank you very much and if
you want to follow us uh our instagram
is at underscore kinetic sg and mine is
at panlim thank you very much guys
thank you pam thank you
i have two questions for you and then i
want to bring the rest of the panelists
back for some other questions that
actually is inspired by your state of
mind manifesto
first question for you though tell us
about the guitars in the background are
you also a musician
and can you play something for us
i can play something for you now but um
yes i'm not really a musician but i do
love music very much yeah
yeah i do i do
and you're a collector i mean i see at
least three guitars there
yeah i i don't consider myself a
collector because i've known collectors
who really collect a lot of them but i
do have quite a number with me but i'm
not sure that considers a collector yeah
but i do have quite a number yeah
um second question i've lied i said i
have two i have three for you but
they're quick they're quick and then
we'll bring everything up quick it's
good yeah
um second question tell us about your
eyeglasses i have eyeglass envy right
now
okay
what do you want to know about the eye
glasses
where they
made them
uh
retro super retro future
or retro super future i can remember one
of them
then yeah i just bought them and uh
i have many pairs of them since you are
asking about
nuggets or facts yeah i hate looking for
glasses
because every time you you change a pair
and you need to get used to your own
face i hate that so
i come a pair after i found a pair that
i don't mind wearing i usually will
buy many of them and just keep
that's it yeah cool and i buy on ebay
yeah
oh really and then you have the lenses
fitted to your two yeah yeah yeah
yeah i just got the lenses fixed here
because you know the degrees change
every half a year to a year
okay last question for you
yeah in the rubbish magazine
yeah did i was i seen correctly it was
the paper pink
oh yes pink
what made you decide to
use pink as the color of the paper
um
okay the pink papers
was of course
our first issue where we decided so what
we liked about
the pink paper was i was just trying to
simulate those really very cheap paper
that people used to
photostat on
so
actually it's a word play on the on the
word fanzine but mine is a family scene
so it's fantastic so why the pink paper
is actually derived from the love of all
this very low budget quality
zines in the past because i used to
collect lots of fanzine as fanzines as
well when i was a teenager
then
why it became color was after everything
was done in black i mean just sharing a
bit of the design process so initially
it was a pink paper
and it was all all the color
photos scanned from the film negatives
were all converted to black and white so
that it looks like photocopy but after a
while it felt like the waste right we
went traveling in tokyo and kyoto for 13
days we had
thousands of nice photos and i just
converted them to black and white and
changed it to photocopy
version which i felt was kind of like a
letdown so then i thought okay why why
be so
rigid with the thinking right
i know usually it starts off as black
and white but i want to do a pink color
version with colored photos
and that's how it started and
on on the first issue you were so basic
there weren't page numbers
there weren't anything it was just
really like
purposefully wanted to be bad you know
yeah
so
thank you thank you i'd like to invite
all the panelists back
um we have a number of questions from
the audience uh i also have a number of
questions but because of the timing i'd
like to focus only on the audience
questions so that we can get to
at least two
um this one came in it's a fairly
complicated question um so i'll read it
out loud
there was some attempt at bridging print
with digital
through qr codes and now ar
etc
this is for all the panelists how do you
see print integrating with digital
especially as digital becomes more
digital nfts the metaverse crypto etc
will the divide broaden
and will print become its own form of
resistance
so i'd like to open this up to any and
all panelists as you see fit pen vanessa
norio
so
um
do i start i i
absolutely you should start because you
are the last speaker and only okay
so
my point of view is this
let's take uh since uh we spoke about
music right so as a music level we all
know that
vinyls are back
right vinyls are back everybody's
playing vinyls these days in fact
cassette tapes are back
so we all also know that spotify is
going strong kaido is going strong so
there will be digital streaming
platforms there will still be people
buying viano platforms to listen so will
we say that the divide for
there's a digital and an analog divide
all i can say is actually there will be
people who still enjoy both and there
will still be people who really want to
purely enjoy music using analog and
there'll be people who think
or rather enjoy the convenience of
streaming music because you can swap
music albums at a flash so i do not see
it very different from print right
even though there's a digital rise
at some point a few that you want to get
back and more in touch with analog again
and i i don't see there's gonna be a
divide or anything it's just that these
two gonna coexist nicely together and at
some point when people have too much of
a digital they're gonna switch to analog
and when you have too much analog you're
gonna go back to digital a bit but
they'll both still be very important i
mean yeah i keep your shot there yeah
that's my thought
thanks pam
vanessa
i'll continue um
my dad has a theory he which i actually
love it's his theory he called it the 50
50. that when civilization moves 50
forward it moves 50 back
and and the way he thinks about it is
not in we're backwards and that i think
that's what's interesting it's actually
we reframe the past so so it shifts you
know the you know i used to have tapes
and
and and i do have a record player now
but it's different higher on a record
plays under my
my records now than when it was in my
house the only source of music now
there's like a ritual to music like i
went back to it just because i wanted to
just hold one
one sound and you know and the same
happens with twit the moment you know
offset became
uh you know was the only way we got our
text and it's only we went to uh sorry
um
uh when we had letterpress we went to
offset letterpress became this
very unique special jewel that we that
you know it was an incentive of all our
senses because it's texture and suddenly
it becomes this very uh unique technique
and and this sort of like this famous
book the object objects so our
relationship to
to that shifts and i think that's what
that's what changes um and and i and the
in between so and there's the counter
culture the more we move into metaverse
the more we move into this world the
more thank god we will rebel as humans
we will rebel and we'll find spaces
again those those in between those
crossovers what i think that's what
truly the most interesting things will
happen
yeah i think that um
back in the early 80s people were
talking about how video was
going to kill the radio star but i think
podcasting would prove that
uh audio entertainment is alive and well
um norio any any thoughts on on this
specific question
know
um if i if i think about my my lifestyle
everyday lifestyle and think about if
everything ever completely 100 became
digital then
i would say
is it would be such a difficult
situation to live
and
if i imagine everything becomes digital
then of course our life life will be
very difficult so we we naturally we
tend to make a balance and we try to
make balance within the physical and the
digital and being a designer uh it's a
it's a it's a
it's an opportunity and also a challenge
to find something
something that is between digital and
the physical and it could be some
new communication it could be some
system it could be some technology and
um and so i always keep myself
challenging uh to find what's what's in
what's in between
yeah i mean i think that
the digital world has forced
those of us that make
print work to have to make it better
uh books are still being sold and the
more books that are
better designed are doing better than
ever before
um i know that we're very close to
running out of time so i have two last
questions i want to try to sneak them in
um
why does print matter especially in
today's
increasingly digitized world this is a
question from the audience why does why
does print matter
i'll jump on that one i think it matters
because um the more digital we become in
all honesty becomes white noise i mean
we again we we we get all of this
information and yet we we have lost
focus we have lost focus i think that we
also an image a friend of mine who's a
photographer told me the moment he puts
an image on instagram he loses 99 of its
value and it's measured not by its
intrinsic value it's not measured by how
it connects to your emotion it's
measured by how many clicks how many
likes likes is an action not a feeling
anymore we don't like something we
actually act on it
so
the the moment you hold a book or an
exhibit you're actually holding a
collective memory and for me that's
what's important we we hold a collective
memory i have books i i like to buy
vintage books i've loved books all my
life have books from the 30s and 50s and
i go back to them and i it's not this
insanity of images that i would find i
actually can have the time to ponder and
to share that experience collectively
and that memory lasts much longer
and and for that alone i think
there is there's value in in what we do
pan norio any anything you'd like to add
to that
um
for me um
i do look at it quite differently i
think print and digital matters both of
them
so i think on the point where for
instance let's say
you have a a distant following online
let's say for instance uh instagram or
tick tock or whatever and let's say you
are launching
a book or something
and you are able
so you're launching a book because you
know you want to talk about you want
people to maybe buy a book or something
uh
i think
it does matter because it really because
consumers
behavior these days is they wake up they
look at their phones
so
you will reach the audience using
digital
but print matters because in the end the
product they hold will be that
particular book that is special if they
want it so for me i do do do think that
uh it does not
translate into like digital does not
devalue anything
but i just feel that it's a mode of
reaching reaching your larger audience a
lot a lot faster and there's also the
ability for them to share to their
friends and they also have the ability
to introduce your work to a larger
larger larger audience which
by using print printed matter in the
earlier days where we mail each other
let's say i just learned something i
mail you and it's a fan mail remember
those days you'll never reach the
audience
so so to me my lens is different
they are all valuable in their own right
we need both of it to live in this world
now so i that's why i never had this
issue about which is rising and which is
falling
do it together yeah i think
yeah i i agree but i do think you know i
was just i just found this dad a couple
of days ago i was doing some research
and
we are in in the cities of the world
being bombarded with anywhere between 10
and 40 000
ads
or images that are selling something per
day
sure and that's and that's being thrust
on us you know that's just in our
purview
there's something very interesting about
being able to be selective about what we
choose to see and i think that's a lot
of what print gives us that we can pick
it up we can engage with it we can
we can touch it
in that physical realm by choice and i
think that's sort of a wonderful thing
um i have one last question i want to
address this to norio first because he
didn't get to answer the last question
and this is sort of an inspirational
something very nice to i think leave
people with
what is the one thing that you love most
about the print format or printed media
this is another audience question
no
teacher
so as as a year old or designers and
they have experienced when you print
once you print
is untouchable you can't change
and that that moment that feeling that
incident is something i i
truly truly adore and i think it's a
very precious
uh
thing
as a as a
as a designer product or whatever
and it's something that almost like uh
living with some animals or living you
know something that has life
and i i cherish that uh that
value
and i i and and that's one of the uh
the most beautiful thing about print
wonderful thank you
pan
okay um
for me
i feel there's a lot to do with
also
as a designer you are connected
to that particular medium so so because
i met people who
[Music]
are trained digitally they have no
passion for the printed method
they don't mind getting a book but they
don't look at books the way we look at
books so sometimes i feel that our point
of view might be also skill and bias to
what we what we love so for that matter
when i buy a book and and i find that
the book cover is so nice when i open
and look at the pages i just feel that
the paper is not appropriate i don't buy
that book so it's a bit of an extreme
measure the content of the book could be
amazing but because of that wrong choice
of paper i don't buy that book
but for another guy who
a friend of mine who just you say pan
you're being silly right the the content
is amazing and i say yeah i understand
that but when i flip through it 100
pages of it is painful for me to go 200
pages of wrong choice of paper but i
mean of course it's subjective so i
think uh our love and passion for the
printed matter
sometimes it's skilled towards
um our own
biases towards it because we love it so
much so if you ask me why does it matter
because it matters i have like hundreds
and hundreds of books my bookshelves are
all double layered i kind of feel
anymore i just feel double layer of
books because i just love the smell the
colors the printing
and i can bring it anywhere i want to
and it's lovely right so yeah that's me
thank you pam vanessa last word is with
you
um i love what everybody said i agree um
i love the richness for me there is it's
a richness in the subtlety and that's
what i like about print that there is
you know it's not about the big platform
it's actually about the quiet space
about those detailings you know when
we're doing a book we're thinking about
what is the what is the the color of the
sewing of the book what is the weight
how does it move you flip it to see if
the weight you choose has the movement
of it what tonality you know um
sometimes experimenting like pain did we
we used pink copy paper like photocopy
paper to use it it for me it's a way of
taking the content and give it more
layers of richness and
making that experience for somebody who
picks it up much more
open-ended it is not linear it is not
this is the information and i think
that's what i wanted to say before as
well is that like pen
i think every
every
project has its own medium it will
determine itself into its medium
and but then when it comes to book we
have a richness and a playground and i
love like architecture to me book is not
that dissimilar it's the materiality
it's the spaciousness it's the movement
all of this rhythm and i find it that's
why i always believe it's like music and
you know what i'm i'm not planning to
give it up i love it
thank you so much i love what you just
said about the layers of richness
um
frankly listening to
you all today and and viewing your work
and hearing how you describe your work
added so much richness to to my
understanding of of what you do and what
is possible with print
um i do want to thank you so much
vanessa x dean norio nakamura kotoko
koya and panlim
everyone at dnad singapore and to you
our audience with their questions and
participation
and for joining us today thank you thank
you thank you
i have to thank you debbie thank you
thanks
thank you debbie so much norio pam a
pleasure thank you thank you very much
thank you everybody
[Music]
thank you thank you so much
bye
thank you debbie vanessa nouriel kotoko
and pan for joining us today and sharing
your insights with us and to our
attendees we hope that you have learned
something valuable today the state of
print exhibition is currently ongoing at
the national design center till the 31st
of july so do pop by if you can to find
out more about the place of printed
matter in a digital age